Okay.
Bitte schau.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Adid, ist mein Name.
Ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt heute.
Ich kenne mich um Sie.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ja, hallo Herr Dr. Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Frau Sabrina Kurvenstein.
Kurvenstein.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname für mich langsam stabilieren?
Sabrina, Sie sind mit Anton Bertha.
Richard Ida, Nordpol Anton.
Das ist mein Vorname.
Und Kurvenstein ist mein Nachname.
Kurve wie die Kurve, K-O-R-V-E-N.
Stein wie Stein, S-T-E-I-N.
Okay.
Kurvenstein, so sage ich richtig, oder?
Das ist ja gut gemacht.
Bevor wir über Ihre Beschwerden spielen,
würde ich gerne einfach eine allgemeine Frage über Sie fragen.
Frau Kurvenstein, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
15. April 1969.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Kurvenstein?
Ich bin auch etwas kleiner geworden.
Ich war zuletzt 1,69 m.
Sie wollen wahrscheinlich jetzt auch mein Gewicht noch wissen.
Gerne.
Ich habe etwas zugenommen.
Ich glaube, ich wiege jetzt im Moment so 72 kg.
72 kg.
Okay.
Was führt Sie für uns heute?
Ich glaube gar nicht, was mir alles zugestoßen ist.
Also lassen Sie mich mal erzählen.
Ich war vor ungefähr zwei Wochen in Österreich im Urlaub.
Und da hatte ich plötzlich Schmerzen und so Brennen im Rücken.
Und zuerst habe ich mir nichts dabei gedacht.
Ich habe mir das herzugenommen.
Seitdem ich hier bin, seit gestern,
merke ich auch so ein Yuk-Rides am Rücken und das Strahl zum Bauch aus.
Vor zwei Wochen waren Sie in Österreich.
Und dann haben Sie da bemerkt,
dass Sie im Rücken brennende Schmerzen haben.
Und zwischendurch haben Ihre Beschwerden sich ihre Beschwerden zugenommen.
Und seit gestern strahlen die Ihre Schmerzen aus Baum.
Ist das wichtig?
Also Richtung meinem Bauch aus, richtig.
Und ich habe einen starken Yuk-Rides bekommen.
Natürlich Schmerzen, brennende Schmerzen und starke Yuk-Rides.
Wo sind Sie genau Ihre Schmerzen?
Schmerzen in der rechten Seite oder linker Seite?
Es ist auf der linken Seite.
Es strahlt vom Rückhänd, von der Wirbelsäule,
bis rüber zum Bauch und in die Leiste ein bisschen.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen oder langsam angefangen?
Die haben langsam angefangen,
aber das hat sich relativ schnell verschlimmert.
Das ist innerhalb von zwei Tagen richtig schlimm geworden.
Ich konnte nachts nicht schlafen.
Und daher bin ich jetzt heute bei Ihnen.
Können Sie sich daran erinnern?
So gibt es eine Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen.
Was ist vor zwei Wochen da passiert?
Haben Sie einen Umfang gemacht oder etwas anderes?
Wir waren im Ski-Olar.
Zuerst habe ich gedacht, dass es in Rückenschmerzen ging.
Es ging relativ schnell wieder weg.
Das war bis gestern oder vorgestern eigentlich ganz okay.
Seit zwei Tagen haben wir wieder extrem und sehr schnell zugenommen.
Ich habe heute Morgen so kleine rote Punkte bemerkt auf der Haut.
Die kleine rote Punkte sind überall oder nur im Bereich von Schmerzen?
Dort wo es weh tut, von Brücken bis zum Bauch.
Genau in diesem Bereich.
Ich habe das Gefühl, diese Punkte nehmen auch zu.
Das hat einen starken Joghreiz.
Das wird immer mehr.
Dafür haben Sie etwas für Ihre Schmerzen eingenommen als Medikamente?
Ich habe gestern Abend die Klack eingenommen.
Das hat nur ganz wenig geholfen.
Aber heute habe ich noch nichts eingenommen, weil ich zu Ihnen kommen wollte.
Meine nächste Frage über Ihre Schmerzen.
Es gibt eine bestimmte Bewegung oder etwas anderes?
Egal wie ich mich bewege oder sitze, das brennt, es ist schlimm.
Aber ein Fieber?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Der ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Da kann ich mich manchmal sogar zu gut.
Aber da kann ich mich nicht beklagen.
Über Ihre Bedeutungssysteme, haben Sie etwas unabhängig gemeint?
Durch Verhalten, Erbrechen, Verstoffung?
Nein, wie gesagt, wir waren im Urlaub.
Das war sehr schön.
Es hat alles gut geklappt.
Aber solche Symptome oder Beschwerden, wie Sie sagen, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich sende etwas mit Ihrem Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen aufgefallen?
Nein, das war alles in Ordnung.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass die letzten Wochen sehr stressig bei uns waren.
Wir haben einen kleinen Umzug vorher gehabt.
Aber jetzt mit dem Urlaub war das wieder etwas besser.
Ich würde gerne über Ihre Vorerkrankungen ein paar Spargestellen.
Haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Zuckerkrankheit oder Hochblutdruck?
Glücklicherweise waren meine Blutwerte immer ganz gut.
Ich habe aber keinen Zucker.
Aber ich habe seit 4-5 Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Was nehmen Sie dafür ein?
Wir heißen das Kandesatan, glaube ich.
Was sind 16 Milligramm?
60 oder 16?
16.
Wie ist Ihnen eine OP bekannt vor Ihrem Vorgeschichte?
Eine Operation?
Ich hatte schon mehrere kleine Operationen.
Vor 10 Jahren hatte ich Schmerzen im Bauch.
Es hat sich als eine Ganblasenentzündung herausgestellt.
Die musste auch operiert werden.
Als Kind hat man mir die Mandel entfernt.
Ich bin beim Skifahren vor vielen Jahren mal hingefallen.
Ich hatte mir den Mittelfußknopf geknackt.
Ich hatte mir den Knopf geknackt.
Ich hatte mir den Mittelfußknopf auf der rechten Seite gebrochen.
Das musste auch operiert werden.
Vor 10 Jahren?
Der Unfall vor 7 Jahren.
Sie haben schon das gesagt.
Vor 7 Jahren haben Sie einen Schneeunfall gehabt.
Außerdem haben Sie eine andere Unfall.
Das ist ein Unfall.
Das reicht.
Ja, ganz alt.
Mein Gynecolo gemeint,
vielleicht muss man noch an der Gebärmutter operieren.
Da sind Miome, die sich auch begrössern.
Aber ich will da jetzt erst mal keine Operation.
Über Ihre gynecologische Anamnese.
Sie sind schon 63 Jahre alt.
Aber haben Sie noch mal Ihre Periode?
Ich bin schon 63.
Anfang 50 ist bei mir die Menopause eingetreten.
Am Anfang hatte ich viele Symptome.
Aber seit 16 Jahren ist alles okay.
Haben Sie Kinder vor Corona?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Meine Tochter und einen Sohn.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja.
Glückweise haben Sie keine Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie Ihre Kinder mit einem Normalgebot gehabt?
Mein Sohn musste mit Kaiserschnitt geboren werden.
Meine Tochter war ein Normalgebot.
Sie haben keine Kinder.
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Sie haben kein Normalgebot.
Sie haben keine Komplikation.
Es gab keine Komplikation.
Sie mussten nicht stationär bleiben?
Nein.
Sie waren mit der Operation.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Sie wurden mit dem Partner ein Ehemann oder Kinder verheiratet?
Ja.
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe ein Ungewohnt.
Ich habe eineouvierend
Ich habe eine jüngere Schwester, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
So weit ich weiß, ja.
Und leben ihre Eltern noch einmal?
Nein, leider nicht, die sind für Storben, ja.
Meine beide halt.
Und wissen Sie, woran sind Sie gestorben?
Also meine Mutter hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Und hat das leider nicht überlebt.
Und wenige Jahre später ist dann mein Vater an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Können Sie daran erinnern, wie alt waren Sie?
Ich oder meine Eltern?
Ihre Eltern, als Sie gestorben sind.
Also mein Vater war circa 80 Jahre alt.
Und meine Mutter für 70.
Und kommen wir fast Ende.
Ich muss nur ein paar andere Fragen stellen.
So, erst mal.
Sie haben schon das gesagt, dass Sie für Ihre Hochglutere
einfach eine Medikamente benutzen.
Und für Ihre Schmerzen haben Sie schon eine Schmerzmittel eingenommen.
Und nehmen Sie eine weitere oder weitere Medikamente ein,
regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Ich nehme noch ein paar Vitamin-Präparate ein,
aber ansonsten keine anderen Tabletten.
Okay, sind Sie durchgeimpft oder gebustet mit der Corona?
Ja, ja, das habe ich alles gemacht.
Also ich bin gebustet.
Meine regulären Impfungen sind auch immer regelmäßig
von meinem Hausarzt kontrolliert worden.
Da sind die auch aufgefrischt.
Ja, das bin ich auch dahinter.
Also das finde ich sehr wichtig.
Okay, bisher bin ich mit meinen Fragen durch.
Möchten Sie etwas anderes hinzufügen?
Was meinen Sie, was es jetzt ist, diese Schmerzen?
So, Frau Kuhnstein, wir sind ganz am Anfang eigentlich so.
Ich weiß, dass ich viele Fragen gestellt habe,
aber ich muss erst mal ihnen körperlich untersuchen.
Dann muss ich Blut abnehmen.
Dann muss ich die mit meinem Oberarzt darüber sprechen.
Dann kommen wir mit einem Diagnose und mit weiteren Lösungen.
Aber machen Sie sich keine...
Ich kann Ihnen gerne die Stelle mal zeigen, wie es aussieht.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Ich habe auch waren ich meine Untersuche machen.
So waren ich Ihnen Untersuche.
So sehe ich auch die Stelle und diese Bereich.
Ja, also es juckt sehr stark.
Schauen Sie mal hier.
Das ist sehr rot. Das ist bläschenartig.
Und nimmt ihn mal zu.
Okay, danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn ich etwas vergessen habe,
kann meine Kollegin gerne hinzufügen.
Wenn Sie mir helfen können, die Schmerzen in Griff zu bekommen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Okay, haben vielleicht andere Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen.
Während der Kollege jetzt ein Gespräch vorbereitet,
das ging jetzt relativ schnell.
Keine Fragen, sehr gut.
Und Herr Doktor, sind Sie soweit?
Nicht noch, ja, machen wir so.
Okay, dann machen Sie mal Ihre Übergabe.
Okay, so, einen guten Tag, meine OB A.
Ich habe heute eine Patiente von, ja,
haben wir uns das schon so aufgenommen.
Darf ich Sie Ihnen vorstellen?
Ja, gerne, Kollege Artigidan.
Schießen Sie mal los.
Okay.
Sabina Kurverstein ist unsere Patientin, 63 Jahre alt
und ein bisschen übergewicht.
Und sie stellt sich wegen vor zwei Wochen
aufgetretende, aufgetretende, aufgetretende,
brennende Schmerzen in ihrer linker Seite rücken.
Und diese Schmerzen strahlen seit gestern aus ihrem Bau.
Und dann hat sie auch bemerkt,
dass sie strahlen, strahlen von Rücken ventral aus.
Und sie hat das auch gleichzeitig juckert als bemerkt.
Und sie hat das gesagt, deine Schmerzen,
ihre Schmerzen, zu sein langsam, langsam aufgetreten,
aber ziemlich schneller verschlimmert.
Und zum Beispiel gestern Abend,
könnte sie nicht mehr schlafen wegen der Schmerz.
Gestern Abend hat sie dafür eine Diplat-Tablete eingenommen.
Aber hat sie das schon gesagt,
dass diese Medikamente ihr nur wenig geholfen haben?
Ja.
Okay.
Und sie hat das auch, das gesagt,
letzte Woche war ihr sehr stressig wegen einer Umzug.
Und außerdem leidet sie an Hochblutdruck seit fünf Jahren.
Und dafür nimmt sie Kantelsartan 60 Milligramm ein.
Nein, wie viel? 16.
16 Milligramm, okay.
Ich habe 16 geschrieben, aber 16 gibt es sich.
16 Milligramm ein.
Und sie hat sich auch in der Schmerzen geholfen.
Und außerdem ihre Vegetarie-Anamnese war unauffällig.
Und sie ist schon in ihrem Männerpause,
Anfang 50 hat sie das schon gesagt,
dass sie ihre Männerpause gehabt hat.
Sie hat zwei, ein Tochter und ein Sohn.
Und sie hat ein Sohn,
sie hat ihre Sohn mit Kaiserschnitt gekriegt,
aber die Kaiserschnitt und die OP war ganz komplikationlos.
Und vor zehn Jahren hat sie eine garne Blattentzündung.
Deswegen hat sie eine OP.
Und als Kind ist ihr ihre Mandel entfernt.
Entfernt worden.
Und vor sieben Jahren hat sie eine OP mit ihrem Mittelfüßknochen.
Aber alle OP-
An ihrem Mittelfüßknochen.
Okay.
Aber alle OP waren komplikationlos.
Alle OP-
Alle OP-s.
Alle OP-s waren.
auffällig, weil ihre Mutter und ihrer Vater wegen der Gefäßprobleme gestorben ist.
So, seine Mutter, wie bitte? Weil ihre Eltern an Gefäßproblemen verstorben sind.
Verstorben sind. Der Vater ist verstorben, aber ist verstorben,
oder wenn zusammen sind, verstorben werden. Aber über ihre Schmerzen, sie hat das schon
berichtet. Ihre Schmerzen haben so eine Gürtelmäßig. Und da hat sie auch heute Morgen
so kleine rote Punkte mit Bläschen bemerkt. So, das ist ja unsere Patientin.
Ich fände gerade auf die Herpes Zoster. Ja, das würde passen von der Beschreibung
von der Klinik. Sehr gut. Wir heißen diese Schmerzen, die im Rahmen von Herpes Zoster auftreten.
Wie nennt man das? Die brennenden Schmerzen. Zosterneuralgie. Oder, man,
dann gibt es ja auch noch, dass wenn die Gürtelrose abheilt, das dauert ja so
circa eine Woche, zehn Tage, dass aber Patienten trotzdem noch brennende Schmerzen
an diesen Dermatomen, sagt man ja dazu, haben. Wir heißen diese Schmerzen Postzosterneuralgie.
Und es gibt ja jetzt eine Impfung, die man dagegen gehen kann gegen diese Postzosterneuralgie.
Das wird für Personen ab 60 Jahren empfohlen. Das sind zwei Impfungen, also Grundimmunisierung.
Und das ist jetzt relativ neu. Ja, genau. Deswegen sage ich das, dass wir auch noch mal nachgucken.
Das nennt sich dann eine Zosterneuralgie-Punkt. Aber sehr gut, ja, das stimmt. Im Moment sind
auch sehr viele Patienten bei mir in der Praxis, die kommen oft mit Gürtelrose. Und das ist
gürtelförmig, meistens am Rücken oder am Bauch. Manche haben das hier vorne an der Brust.
Und der Verlauf kann manchmal sehr kompliziert und sehr schwierig sein oder auch sehr schwerwiegend
sein. Ja, mit Brennen, mit Schmerzen, mit großen Glasen. Und deswegen muss man da auch mit sehr
starken Schmerzmedikamenten arbeiten. Was würden Sie empfehlen? Wie sieht die Therapie
bei Herpes Zoster aus? Wo sind die erfahrenen Fachärzte, Internisten, Hautärzte? Wer ist dabei heute?
Wir haben insgesamt 16 Ärztinnen. Wer kann dem Kollegen helfen?
Arziklovir. Das hört sich doch schon mal ganz gut an. Also ein Alpivirostatikum. Wir können
Sie auch die Dosierung sagen. Wie viel? Ich weiß nicht. Wer weiß es? Keiner. Also es gibt
die Möglichkeit. Arziklovir, 800 Milligramm, fünfmal am Tag. Das muss man regelmäßig nehmen.
Das ist gegen das Virus. Dann gibt es dieses Bürovidin. Ich glaube, das ist das Zosteks. Dann
gibt man nur eine Tablette am Tag. Das wäre gegen den Zoster. Man muss nicht, aber man kann.
Wenn man das frühzeitig in den ersten, ein, zwei Tagen gibt, dann ist es sehr sinnvoll. Da hat ein
Kollege hingeschrieben Gabapentin. Warum Gabapentin? Dr. Atici. Warum gibt man Gabapentin?
Es ist auch eine Schmerzengelände. Es ist gegen Neurologie eigentlich schon. Genau. Das ist
eine Sparke. Es ist ein sehr medikamentgegenen, also gegen neupargische Schmerzen. Genau. Wo
gibt man das noch? Bei welchen Neurologischen Schmerzen gibt man Gabapentin noch? Bei Diabetikern?
Polyneuropathie. Die bekommen oft auch Gabapentin gegen diese neuralgischen Schmerzen. Sehr gut.
Was macht man gegen den Yukreiz, gegen die Bläschen? Wer weiß es? Wer ist dabei? Man schreibt oft
eine Salbe auf, eine Creme. Die soll diese Bläschen trocknen und auch diesen Yukreiz
wegnehmen. Da gibt es verschiedene Medikamente. Eines davon nennt sich Anesthesulf. Einfach eine
Lotion, eine Weiselotion. Anesthesulf, so wie Anesthesi, aber Anesthesulf nennt sich das. Wie gesagt,
da kann man auch andere Medikale sagen oder Creme auch aufschreiben, damit der Yukreiz und diese
flüssige Form nachlässt. Worauf muss man den Patienten hinweisen, wenn man so eine
Gürtelrose festgestellt hat? Worauf muss er achten, wenn sie ihn mit einer Partner lebt oder
mit Kindern zusammen in einer Wohnung sind? Können die anderen Kollegen helfen? Ansteckung? Sehr gut.
Das heißt, solange die Bläschen Wasser gefüllt sind und sie immer mit der Hand hinkommen,
weil sie juckt und weh tut, dann ist es ansteckend. Das heißt, man muss die Patienten
darauf hinweisen, dass sie immer Hände, immer Waschen und desinfizieren und am besten kein Körperkontakt,
bis die oder solange die Bläschen vorhanden sind. Ja, sehr gut. Was sind die Differenzialdiagnosen zum
Abschluss? Woran muss man auch denken, wenn es keine Gürtelrose ist? Herr Attiti,
Sie werden heute sehr alleine gelassen. Ihre Kollegen helfen Ihnen heute nicht so.
Ja, Sie haben mich bezügt.
So, wo sind die? Jawohl. Also sehr gut. Jetzt kommt es. Erstens. Ein Diskus pro Laps. Also,
das kann eine Lumbalgie von der Lendenwirbelsäule sein, klar, oder von der Brustwirbelsäule,
eine Lumbalgie oder Lumboychialgie wegen einem Bandscheimvorfall oder ein Diskus pro Laps.
Okay. Und FSME, natürlich solche neurologischen Beschwerden können eine Borreliose sein,
zum Beispiel jetzt nicht unbedingt FSME, das macht eher eine Hirnhautentzündung,
eine meningitis, Früh, Sommer, meningorentzifalitis, FSME, aber eher eine Borreliose
wahrscheinlich. Muss man auch mal dran denken. Da muss man diesen Borrelientiter im Blut bestimmen,
um das festzustellen. Was gibt man denn, wenn es eine Borreliose ist? Welches Medikament? Wo sind
die Neurologen? Welches Antibiotikum? Ich helfe mal ein bisschen. Doxycycline. Ja, wer hat das gesagt?
Wie heißt die Kollegin? Ja, mein Name ist Mfeshev, aber das ist mein Mann,
bei meinem Handy. Sehr gut, Frau Mfeshev, Frau Doktor, sehr gut. Das ist richtig. Ganz toll. Also
doxycycline, sehr gut. Herr Doktor Artesi schaut nach und guckt, wie die Dosierung von doxycycline ist,
wenn man eine Borreliose hat. Sehr gut. Weitere Differenzialdiagnosen. Wo muss man noch denken?
Linkszeitige Flankenschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in die Leiste. Intercostale Neurologie ist richtig.
Woran noch? Linke Flanke mit Ausstrahlung. Nephrolitiasis, sehr gut. Nierensteine,
Hanleitersteine. Sehr gut. Was ist noch auf der linken Seite? Welches Organ? Letzte Frage und
dann lasse ich Sie in Ruhe heute. Linke Flanke, welches Organ ist da? Hanwexinfektion. Hanwexinfektion,
pylonefrittis. Was noch? Was ist neben den Nieren noch? Um. Milz, genau. Also eine
Milzproblematik, weswegen auch immer ein Milz infragekt, eine Milzentzündung, eine
Beinblutung in den Milz, eine Milzvergrößerung, eine Splenomegalie, zum Beispiel durch eine
Virusinfektion. Welche Springen von Punkt zu Punkt, welche Virusinfektion macht eine Hepatoseplenomegalie?
Haben viele junge Menschen manchmal.
Epstein-Barbirus. Epstein-Barbirus, eBV, wie nennt sich das noch? Monolucneose oder
pfeifrisches Drüsenfieber. Sehr gut. Letzte Differenzialdiagnose noch und dann sind wir
fertig. Linkseitige Schmerzen mit Ausstrahlung, zum Teil mit Brennen.
Vielleicht wegen der Eistur, weil es eine Frau ist?
Das ist aber eher im Unterbau und wir sind ja hier relativ oben.
Blankem. Ich denke an die Lunge, zum Beispiel eine atypische Pneumonie, eine
Pleuritis, ein Pleurahmpieh im Unterlappen. All das kann auch mal solche Symptome machen.
Reppenbruch.
Reppenbruch, ja natürlich stimmt. Sie ist ja schie gefahren und gleich ist sie
hingefallen und hat ein Reppenbruch und sie hat es gar nicht gemerkt. Sehr gut.
Okay, Herr Atiji, vielen Dank. Ich danke auch anderen Kollegen.
Ich hoffe erst mal so weit in Ordnung und ich war nicht zu streng mit ihnen.